the protest organized by the family was
much larger than expected
thousands throughout brazil calling for
justice for moise cabangambe a congolese
migrant whose face is now everywhere
he's become a symbol for the black lives
matter movement
moisea was brutally beaten to death in
this beach kiosk where he used to work
it's in the same neighborhood where
president jair bolsonaro owns a house
this neighborhood is where brazil's
elite lives he was treated like an
animal like a thing just because he was
claiming two days of overdue wages some
twenty dollars
we're all here because we want black
people to be treated like humans moyes
could have been my son my brother my
cousin
cctv released by the police show moise
arguing with a man he was taken down by
others beaten with a club and a baseball
bat and tied to a pole
black people represent more than half of
brazil's population the largest number
outside of africa
[Music]
what has changed since the times of
slavery moyes was tied and beaten to
death in public as if he were a thing
moyes's family fled the warren congo in
2014
his mother asked for justice and peace
we ran away from violence in a civil war
to find more violence
suzette gomez a teacher and activist
says moyes's tragic death is now uniting
brazilians against discrimination
we have to unite and fight for
minorities indigenous people black
people gay people
the murder happened during an electoral
year with president bolsonaro aiming for
a second term
but these protesters say that the
president's silence shows how little he
has done to protect minorities
manuka yanakiv al-jazeera